was glaubt netz willkommen beim neuen
video ich habe heute ein kumpel von mir
dabei uns weiß dass herr dass der
einzige herrschaft der ganzen welt also
hrt
auch wenn viele von euch danach nicht
kennen er es trotzdem cool und wir
machen heute zusammen video und zwar
dinge die wirklich jeder von euch schon
mal gemacht habt ihr unzählige
rausgesucht und stoppte fünf dinge sind
jetzt hier auf meinem channel der dann
fünf auf seinen channel jetzt schon
einen kanal gemacht schmeckt es auf
jeden fall nach dem video ab also jetzt
erst das gucken könnte dann auch gern
nach oben da las und dann geht er auf
seinem kanal guckt euch das an wenn es
euch gefällt dann abonniert ist auf
jeden fall würde mich sehr freuen
übrigens aber gar nicht angelaufen wir
fangen direkt mit punkt eins und das ist
folgendes kennt das ohne witz jeder von
euch ich will gar nicht so viel verraten
wir fangen noch mal an also hier
bitteschön versorger jetzt kann ich auch
was hier noch erzählen wollten was mir
christ und passiert ist sollte erzählen
was passiert dass ich das erzähle meine
wenn es mal auch ja englisch und zwar
auf dem mega zählen dazu sagen kannst du
auch von mir mal die ganze nacht zu
sagen wir zum auf die ganze zeit das
blech zu sagen wie ich das nervt voll
junger künstler der selbst zu sagen wie
ich mal das netz soll hier bist du
irgendwie aber nur was ist mit ihrem
bestehen heute okay da nicht weiter fans
nicht allzu weiter ferne gut alles gut
kennt ihr das leute ihr guckt einen film
dann auf einmal kommt diese musik schaut
euch einfach an
heute kommt zum nächsten moment zwar das
haben doch alle von euch bestimmt mit
vier oder fünf jahren gemacht also eher
so als kind klar heute sogar zum
kühlschrank geht das ist es also heute
doch mal zum kühlschrank guckt man ja
mal rein so also das kennt
wahrscheinlich auch jeder von euch ob
jetzt noch was drin ist oder nicht wenn
man lange weil man geht so hinter hp
dazu guckt so wieder rein c macht mir
dazu den spaß aber früher als kind hat
man mal folgendes gemacht viel spaß
kennt ihr das leute ihr wollt jemand
etwas zeigen auf was sag ich mal so ein
richtig hübsches mädchen oder anders
milch dann drückt ihr zwar irgendwo hin
aber nicht aus profilbild
richey lebst du okay leute den letzten
punkt bzw
jetzt den fünften punkt es geht dabei
ihn weiter habe ich eben schon gesagt
das habe ich so ich habe das so gerne
gemacht heutzutage tu mir die leute dann
immer schon leid also ich mache das
eigentlich gar nicht mehr ich bin da
schon ich bin eigentlich auch schon zu
alt für uns wahr wenn so ein kunde bei
euch war er in seinem facebook account
war nach hause fährt er in einem pc geht
und er folgendes passiert vergessen
das muss ich jetzt auf 50 leute das
war's mit diesem video metrix feier ist
auf jeden fall daumen nach oben da
steckt jetzt das video von ihm ab das
ist hier ein mal verlinkt und auch und
in der video beschreibung passte auch
ein abonnement
und ja natürlich sagen wir sehen uns am
nächsten sondern wieder aber nicht
vergessen